welcome to everybody watching I'm Jason
gots with big thing and this hangout is
brought to you by big think mentor our
lifelong learning platform on YouTube
for personal and professional growth i'm
here with ellen galinsky president of
the families and Work Institute and
author of mind in the making she's here
to talk about the seven essential life
skills that are the subject of her book
and her workshop for a big think mentor
welcome Alan thank you for being with us
thank you so much Jason it's a real
pleasure and I'd also like to welcome
three members of our big think mentor
community um Christian Creek oh and
please correct me if I say your name
room uh Nicholas Oh actually Nikolas and
horn couldn't be with us and Patrick
Johnson welcomed us thank you very much
okay so I'd like to start us off with a
question for Ellen and so there was a
big article this week in New York
magazine which I'm sure you saw on the
negative power of praise and it's one of
many such articles I've seen recently
American parents tend to focus on
boosting kids self-esteem and maybe
western parents generally but the
research of psychologists carol dweck
and others suggest strongly that
overpraise can actually demotivate kids
making them reluctant to work at things
that don't come so easily to them so
they give up more easily um how
seriously should parents teachers and
even employers take this message or
these findings should we be going back
to the days when teachers followed the
maximum no smiling before christmas is
you know is that is that you know is it
that serious and that substantial as
carol dweck says we have been through
the self-esteem movement and she did a
survey and found that the large majority
of parents believed that the way that
you boost kids self-esteem is by
praising them but it's not that it's
praise per se that's bad it's the kind
of praise that that really matters most
parents and most of us play
praise personality we praise character
we say you're really smarter you're a
good artist or and we don't praise the
things that motivate us to try harder to
try that that next challenge to take on
a challenge in in the mind of the making
view that that this is one of the
important life skills if we praise both
adults and children's effort you tried
really hard or you did this particular
use this particular strategy that is we
praise strategies then then kids then
adults will will work hard will stay
motivated and there's also research that
says that that the praise whether you
give very specific and concrete praise
or larger global praise also matters
that is if you're trying something
that's a real challenge then talking
about very specific first steps that an
adult might take tends to be more
motivating not I'm going to lose weight
but I'm going to lose five pounds so
that also matters in terms of how we
talk to people and how we talk to
ourselves great um no I'd like to open
the floor to Christian and Patrick and
and we'll just go round robin christian
if you could ask one question and then
patrick and then we can go back to
christian and patrick and do two
questions each that way and then great
great from that thanks jason i want to
thank big think and and Alan this is a
great opportunity it's a very exciting
the opportunity to speak the wreck with
you and hear your insights the first
question I had Alan was in school number
three communicating well not employers
are reporting that communication is a
critical skill that the younger
workforce is lacking um is there a
particular cost that you see for why
that's the case in the workforce we ask
an open-ended question of a nationally
representative sample of employers in
the research that the families and Work
Institute does and way by and large they
said that young people new entrance to
the workforce are not very good at both
world and written communication and I
think that it's because we don't teach
people to communicate in a sense you can
easily blank brain you know the the
Twitter world and the fact that we're
not really talking face-to-face for this
and and I'm sure that that has a part in
in how we communicate but we need to
teach people what I would think of is
the elevator speech that is think about
if you have a limited amount of time to
communicate one what do you really want
to say and then two and this would
involve the skill perspective taking how
do you say it in a way that it can be
heard and that how do you say it in a
way that it can be heard we're not
teaching children were not teaching
adults how to do that my daughter got a
home masters in strategic communication
she spent you know two and a half years
at Columbia because she runs a
non-profit philanthropy that fun social
entrepreneurs and she finds that the
entrepreneurs that they fund they
started teach for america city year etc
she finds that the entrepreneurs who
succeed are the ones who are good
communicators and although they may have
a big bold idea to as social
entrepreneurs that can solve a really
tough problem if they don't know how to
communicate it well then they don't
necessarily succeed so she felt that in
her job is running this organization
called echoing green that if she could
help their grantees learn to communicate
better they would be able to achieve
their goals in much better ways gotcha
thank you I'm Patrick my first question
was on perspective taking mm-hmm and it
was about how we live in such a
competitive world how does empathy or
emotional intelligence lighten
competition well it's interesting that's
a great question because in some ways we
we live in a very competitive world
yet in the business world the the end of
the era of the individual hero i think
is gone that is we can't just depend on
the jonas salt to come up with a polio
vaccine it's going to take a team and
the smart employers i think our building
in team competencies not just individual
competencies where the chemist and the
physicist or or the biologists if you're
talking about prevention of disease have
to figure out how to work together and
so I think that teaching the skill of
perspective taking is critically
important now it's different than
empathy it involves empathy which is I
feel what you feel it's emotional
intelligence is in a sense a good
concept because it involves intelligence
its social emotional and cognitive
competencies and it helps you understand
the perspectives of others and I can
give an example I always think of
Admiral Michael Mullen who was the chair
of the Joint Chiefs of Staff and when he
and he was quite successful in his job I
think at least I feel he was when he
talks about what helped him go into a
into a country like Afghanistan or Iraq
or Iran he didn't do the usual here's
the history here's the geography here
are the key facts that you need to know
what he tried to understand is how
people who grew up in that culture would
think and that really helped him succeed
or you think of medical school there is
read the cost i read in the New York
Times today that the cost of health care
is going up and it keeps going up one of
the ways to control the cost of health
care is to improve patient doctor
communication that involves perspective
taking so medical schools are
increasingly asking future candidates
their rating future candidates on
whether or not they can listen to the
patient understand the patient's own
view of his or her symptoms and then
communicate back so that there's a
back-and-forth communication and that's
they found that is one way that they can
control costs to reduce our you know to
reduce the price of healthcare as it
escalates in this country so i think
that the notion of the competitive world
is an industrial era yes of course we're
very competitive yes of course I want my
organization to to win to succeed and
I'm sure all of us want to on an
individual level but we can do that best
by working with other people not by you
know putting them down and pushing them
off to the side of the road thank you
great and back to Christian well thank
you and it seems this these skills that
seems so fundamental right this baseline
fundamentals that there it's ironic that
we're forgetting about them it's not
like this is not like new stuff at all
um it's just it's not mean it's your
point as we're industrialization is uh
you know has happened that you know I'm
in the technology world it's so easy to
think well technology is is the solution
but without the people and without the
communications that you speak to
technology is his worthless things
better in fact you know I deal obviously
in the marketplace with a lot of things
I was doing it yesterday and just
counting on computer screens to have all
the right information doesn't have the
interaction happening you don't get the
social aspect to it you don't get people
to help because well the computer screen
just says this so therefore i'm on to
the next customer uh-huh you're missing
the fundamentals exactly I mean it does
seem that these skills are obvious and
yet I spent I was went into what became
mine to the making i didn't start out to
write a book i didn't start out to do
something called mind in the making i
started out with a real question which
is what do we do to children to turn off
the fire in their eyes all children are
born engaged in learning it's a survival
skill our brains are of all other beings
in the world our brains are less
developed at birth than any other
species so we have to we depend on the
environment to write the script for our
genetic codes in a sense if you want to
use a technology analogy so so much of
who we
and what we are comes from the
experiences we have after we were born
in fact they're calling the first three
months of life the fourth trimester
these days because so much is happening
during that time I could see across
disciplines that there are these skills
that that are emerging and yet most
schools most classrooms most parents
don't promote these skills and so it's
it's like hidden in plain sight it's
obvious but we're not paying attention
to it in a fundamental way and but when
you know it when you think about it then
it becomes obvious so the way that I
came up with seven and seven seems like
oh y'all good publishing number did you
just come up with seven because the
publisher said that would be a good
number no I mean what I really did was
to take what i was seeing in the
research from neuroscience from
cognitive science from developmental
psychology etc and look at where there
were longitudinal studies what had
happened in that child's life to help
that child throg now and in the future
and that's how the seven skills actually
emerged in a sense the seventh skill is
kind of cumulative which is
self-directed engaged learning it kind
of pulls them all together and focus in
self-control the first skill is is a
baseline in a sense because if you can't
pay attention you can't really learn the
other skills if you don't have a
self-control to not go on automatic then
you can't really learn to listen to what
someone else says for example what's
perspective-taking but you know the
response to mine in the making has been
so much more than I ever expected
because these are obvious but they're
hidden in plain sight but they're so
simple to do something about I mean we
can teach these two adults we can teach
them to children we can promote them in
ourselves and it can make a big
difference in our lives if I can
interject before we take it over to
Patrick again you know one of the things
Ellen that I like most about what you're
saying in the book and in the mentor
workshop is that the seven essential
life skills basically you know which are
the skills that we need to
be fully functional successful human
beings basically come down to learning
as a life like a lifelong orientation
toward learning they enable us to learn
they they you know they make us
effective learners and and it sort of
represents human beings as learning
being throughout the lifespan which is
something that I mean on there you know
two things one is we tend to think of
learning as something that stops when
you graduate from graduate school I mean
not not you know in some ways no but in
some ways yes like I'm done my learning
and now i'm doing my life um you know
and and and and so the idea of that that
you're learning throughout your life is
not something that people necessarily
actively engage in you know um past
school and then you know secondly we
always have this back and forth where on
the one hand we understand that it's
good for children to be curious and that
we want them to be active learners you
know in education and designing
curriculum and so forth and on the other
hand we have these exigencies of skills
and so forth that we feel we have to
teach children concrete things so that
they can remain competitive and so forth
and so on that often you know create
curriculums and school systems that do
the exact opposite that as you say put
out the fire and no children sighs yeah
so I mean um you know I wonder kind of
what it would take for the orientation
of whole educational systems to shift in
such a way that we are focusing on these
kind of meta skills that make for better
learners you know not only in
progressive schools but also you know
everywhere more than we are on concrete
right no that is such a great question i
just love that so much because and all
of these are great questions and the
reason that i love it so much is that
it's it's like the notion of
competitiveness me against you always
and none of us are going to you know do
anything that matters without the help
of other people in one way or another
whether it's reading a book or actually
working with people who are as far our
sponsors or mentors or so forth the
notion of learning
is a very industrial era notion now I
think of the movie waiting for superman
and there's an image in it or I want
will where I went to myself and I
watched it that is exactly the way we
think about learning this was a school
presumably about education that work
waiting for superman and yet the image
was of a kid whose head was cut off and
numbers and letters and shapes and stuff
report in so we have this toddler raza
this kind of empty vessel will pour in
the knowledge notion when everything we
know about brain science says that we
are active learners yesterday I met with
an entrepreneur who whose company has
made a lot of money and they want to
figure out how to improve the
educational system because they're not
happy with the new entrance to the
workforce and he's trying to learn about
education he's going around the country
and figuring out what works and what
doesn't work and he was really
discouraged because he says thought that
most innovation in education depended on
the one charismatic leader and yes it
does if we keep the old model going but
if everyone becomes a learner then in
and and if we're always trying to
improve things then we can keep
improving education to better fit but we
know from science and a better fit what
we need in the 21st century I don't
think that I would have seen the skills
honestly if so much of my work at the
families and Work Institute weren't with
the adult workforce and workplace I mean
I just have you know here that
discussion all day long and you know in
the research that we do and in the
employers we work with so one thing that
has really gratified me and I'm sorry
this is a long answer but you've gotten
my my soapbox here is that we are out
now in about 14 communities where we
have taken the book and turned it into
training modules and and there and
they're really actually we call them
learning modules not training modules
goes training is the old view of what
learning is but learning modules and
I've seen that fire come back in adult
size
the teachers the principal's the
superintendent's the pediatricians the
social workers the language therapists
they get excited about learning by going
out because we share the actual research
you see Carol Dweck you know in life
living color doing her studies and
talking about what she found in our
modules you have really experiences in
learning yourself and we've seen that
have the ability to begin to transform
the educational system in ways that
honest to god I didn't think we're
possible but when you get adults excited
when they own the innovation that they
need when they base it on science I
think we can begin to reinvent the way
we think of think the way we think about
teaching and learning great um and
Patrick I'm sorry I jumped in there but
I definitely you know was sparked by
what was going on in the conversation so
go ahead and please ask your at your
next question definitely um yeah I agree
with you about the way we learn and how
it uh how we think about it like
socially cognitively emotionally and how
we can relate that to school and within
like this classroom lectures and
independent reading independent learning
and also like clinical rotation or
something where you get hands-on
experience so I can see where I can see
your point there um I'll go to my next
question here it's on critical thinking
and it was um how can we generate how
can critical thinking generate positive
or negative actions and reactions that's
a great question a complicated question
I feel that the world is so a wash with
information that is very hard to know
what's what's real I mean you can watch
the same news story on two different
channels and to get to totally same
event presumably and you get two totally
different interpretations depending on
the point of view of the commentator and
the channels that you've happen to turn
into a radio the same or newspapers the
same anyway that we get information
about the world that we don't directly
experience and how do we know how to
make decisions because our decisions who
we vote for
how we live our lives depend on how we
see this experience that where we don't
have direct knowledge of it I mean we
can't you know maybe in in a very pre
industrial agricultural world we could
have direct experience with everything
that we needed to know about we can't do
that anymore we have we have to
outsource our knowledge so I think that
by and large critical thinking is an
important skill because it's the ongoing
searching the word ongoings is critical
here the ongoing search for ballot and
reliable information so you have to
understand when information is not
accurate when it's what researchers
would call confounded because you can't
say that a always leads to be you you
know it's just it's more complicated
than that and other things get in there
and so I think teaching children not
just let's say science but how
scientific thinking takes place has been
found to improve them in all sorts of
other areas i'm thinking of the research
that's going on at carnegie mellon by
David Clarke for example he found that
kids in the seventh grade eighth grade
etc were never thought how to conduct a
good experiment they were always told
here's the experiment and here's what it
learned but not how do you know whether
it's a really good experiment and when
he actually taught kids how what a good
experiment was and how would how would
you know what you've learned from this
experiment it made a big difference in
in the kids lives and performance so I
think by and large it's mostly a
positive result but of course you know
we get lots of knowledge that it's hard
to figure out whether it is reliable and
accurate and I guess that's the bad side
of it how do we know with you know the
thousands of Twitter fees we get every
day what's real and what's not real
definitely and I think that's what kind
of Drew me too big think is um why not
independently learned myself I go I'll
use like databases through school and
like go after research-based articles
and there's a bunch information you know
bunch of different article
bunch of and places to draw this
information from and I'm not saying it
was a bad way to do it but um I like how
big thing takes it into a different
perspective and like kind of breaks it
down for you and helps you understand it
in in terms of your own life and what
you're doing so thank you for that well
I'm a total fan of big think when when
we decided to work together I was like I
couldn't have been more wildly excited
as Jason knows because he got my
euphoric email us back to him when we
started this conversation I think that
it brings people together in a way that
we can now with technology I mean we can
have this conversation and you know you
can push back at me and I love that and
I can hopefully push back at you and I
love that too we can have we can do the
big thinking that we need to do to be
able to live our lives in the way that
we want to yeah i mean we're um not to
turn this into an extended advertisement
for a big thing but um but you know
having worked here for two years I what
I like best about it is the fact that
you know we can connect with people like
you Ellen and that now through you know
through through mentor and things like
this hangout you know we can actually
connect directly with our audience in
spite of the fact that what we do kind
of happens out there on the big
impersonal web and you know in the past
we've mainly been feeding you know video
out to the world it's it's it's amazing
now to be able to just sit and interact
in this way and really kick the ideas
around um so I think we've we've really
come up to the end of our half hour and
so I want to say thank you to everybody
out there in the audience for joining us
today um and and thank you especially
Ellen Galinsky for being with us you've
been watching our big think mentor hang
out with Ellen Galinsky who's author of
mind in the making and you can visit
youtube.com / user / big think mentor to
view Ellen's video workshop based on her
book called the seven essential life
skills
and thank you so much for being with us
also today Christian and Patrick thank
you it's great thank you thank you as a
pleasure to meet you youtube definitely
you here